and it begins in kansas city where the
nfl
traveled to meet with chief's receiver
tyree kill i'm told it was an eight-hour
meeting lisa freel the nfl special
counsel for investigations was there
along with her assistant jennifer
gaffney eight hours of conversation the
primary topics whether to what extent
tyreek hill's comments that were
recorded by crystal espinal amount to
threats that could be disciplined by the
nfl under the personal conduct policy
whether there was any discipline of his
three-year-old child that crossed the
line into abuse that could be
disciplined by the nfl under the
personal conduct policy and then finally
a very nuanced and and delicate question
the conditions that resulted in a
three-year-old boy being removed from
the care and custody of tyreek hill and
crystal espinal do those conditions
amount to an independent violation of
the personal conduct policy because
there's language in there about actions
that cause danger and the risk of harm
to others now
whatever the situation may have been it
was bad enough to get the state to
intervene and remove the child so
there's three different areas
eight hours of discussion
no decisions yet what will happen is the
nfl will decide whether or not to
discipline tyree kill and if discipline
is forthcoming tyreek hill would go to
manhattan meet with the commissioner
find out what the punishment is he would
have appeal rights but
you're appealing back to the person who
made the decision in the first place
it's very rare that the appeal is
successful
these are things that are going to play
out over the next next few weeks chris
there's an expectation we're going to
have an answer by the time the chiefs go
to training camp on july the 23rd yeah i
would hope so and and mike i ask you
this and this type of case here right
with this whole situation now you know
tyree kill we know he has like you know
pre-existing history right before he got
into the nfl you know if memory serves
me correct they did not really
investigate what happened there but we
know he pled guilty and had his issues
there now on a day like yesterday will
they dive back into the prior history of
what happened between espanol and tyree
kill as far as the first incident prior
to being in the nfl to get context of
the relationship do you go there on
these type of matters or is it just
strictly the matter at hand
i think every investigator
will have their own approach for how
they handle something like this but
you're right he did plead guilty to
assaulting crystal espinal when she was
pregnant in december of 2014. that is
before he entered the nfl so the nfl
can't suspend him for that right but it
can be an aggravating factor in any
suspension that is imposed now so if
it's going to be four games they can
bump the six games if they want to
because of that past incident if i were
the one investigating this and meeting
with tyree kill i would want to ask him
questions about that right just to test
his truthfulness because we know he's
already pleaded guilty so what what kind
of a story is he going to try to sell me
when that comes up again how is he going
to act what's his demeanor going to be
is he going to seem irritated or
frustrated he has to talk about it or is
he going to be contrite and tell me the
whole story and happily go down that
rabbit hole even though he would prefer
not to so i i think from the standpoint
of getting an idea of what kind of a
witness i'm dealing with how truthful
how credible he is
i think there's value in asking him
those questions getting him you know you
want to see you you know what if mr hyde
is lurking around inside of dr jekyll
yeah you'll want to try to draw him out
and that's the kind of thing that could
maybe draw him out yeah that's what i
was thinking or i just wondered how much
they would you know venture down that
road because yeah i would want to ask
them those questions too knowing that
you know they could have the information
and the answers and those things and
kind of double double check what he's
saying to yes make sure you're kind of
getting okay we're getting a straight
shooter today who even though this is
embarrassing and he's done some bad
things at least he's telling us the
truth uh i would think you would want
the context there either way but it's
good to see that the nfl have finally
sat down with tyree kill gets this
investigation going it's good for the
nfl to get it going it's good for the
kansas city chiefs uh and that situation
and we'll see where it all plays out but
it's huge as far as just dictating the
nfl this season i mean just as far as
far as play on the field we're talking
about arguably the best receiver in
football certainly the most explosive
weapon in football and he might not be
available to one of the best offenses
best offensive minds and of course one
of the most dangerous quarterbacks in
the game and that that can change things
around and the powers that be in the afc
and to the extent that people are
curious as to what the nfl is going to
do the easy answer is whatever it wants
to do because at this point the personal
conduct policy has evolved to a juncture
where the nfl can do whatever it wants
to do and we don't know what the nfl
wants to do but there's enough meat
there that if they choose to suspend him
12 games or more full season if they
want to they'd be able to get away with
it and there really isn't much the
player can do about it because the
appeal rights are limited and we have
seen over the past few years the court
cases
do not succeed the way it's set up the
nfl has the power to make these
decisions
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports